i am really excited to try one of the
few usb microphones that's
revolutionizing the streaming world
which comes packed with cool features
like a shock absorber and its own
software we have the razer 7v2 pro usb
microphone that is also a dynamic
microphone and it is made for streamers
and today we will be testing this bad
boy out and certain conditions that you
streamers and podcasters out there may
run into while joining stuff live
so
let's get into it
[Music]
just to let you know we are using the
sirian v2 pro throughout the entire
video so you get a better sense of how
you would sound like while you are
recording so for the first test it is a
tippy tappy task on the army desk
to be a little more realistic with the
test let's get a keyboard and mouse over
to see how it performs like
when you're gaming aggressively or just
casually surfing the web
[Music]
alright now that we're done with the
casual bit let's get into something more
aggressive
so after the first three tasks i think
it's safe to say that if you are
planning to get this you may want to
invest in an arm to mount the mic on to
keep it off any sort of surface but i
need to say that after reviewing the
playback the serum v2 pro no matter how
loud i went has never peaked once that
is because the serene v2 pro can
automatically adjust its my gain
settings so that you don't experience
any kind of peaking while you're
recording audio next up i'm thinking of
you music streamers out there so i took
zaki's guitar and i'm sitting here
comfortably thanks to the folks at
secret lab
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
circle lectures especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if pu leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
tyson evo is even magnetized allowing
the hit pillow to stick on the headrest
of course there are even more new
features so do check them out at
secretlab.co
so the high pass filter and analog gain
limiter are on in synapse so let's just
play some tunes
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah that's how it sounds like with a
high pass filter and analog galaxy on so
let's just review the playback real
quick
and again i have to say that we have not
experienced any form of peaking so far
even though we are pretty loud which
kind of cuts into the next segment you
know as gamers when we get excited we'll
start shouting we'll get loud so let's
see how the razer v2 pro handles that so
let's imagine you're dueling with
another sniper across the ridge you're
missing all your shots you're running
out of rounds and eventually you get
killed by that sob so we're gonna start
with the easy stuff
how did i miss that how did i miss that
look he's right there he's he's right
there
dude can you get it for me no
what come on
no smidgen more to the left no
no
still there's no peeking and no clipping
in the audio so
we're good here so for this last test we
still have the high pass filter and
organ limiter still on and synapse so
the situation for this test is how you
may be streaming with another person in
the room playing their own games
and we have zacky over there he's
playing some battlefield 2042
and you can clearly hear everything
still coming in even with the analog
gain with the high pass filter on
so this is basically how it sounds like
when you have the serum v2 pro with the
high pass filter and analog gain limited
on in synapse while someone else is
playing games on their speaker in the
room after reviewing the playback you
know i'm quite satisfied with how my
voice turned out even with keeping in
the background and quite honestly
it works
so we've put the razer series v2 pro
through its paces and i gotta say that
razer loyalists will definitely pick
this one up however for the rest of us
we have a ton of options on the market
though this is one that you may want to
consider for what it's worth is a pretty
solid mic with a few kinks here and
there though its shortcomings can be
remedied with a bit more time on the mic
and razor synapse
so that's all we have for the razer
series v2 pro are you going to pick one
up do you have any questions that we can
help you clarify leave them all in the
comments section down below don't forget
to follow us on all of our socials and
remember to hit that like and subscribe
button it helps us out a lot
with that this is your boy zinio signing
off take care
[Music]
you